how often do you watch a movie
uh it changes now the pandemic really
did change things for me I used to be
the movie guy
movies only TV show what's that never
gonna watch it
pandemic completely changed that I
started seeing the movies that were
coming out during the pandemic and I
don't know if it's something with the
studios that they were trying to release
films that I would label as lesser than
they just didn't hit the way that a lot
of movies that I seen in years prior
what
so I was watching these movies at home
and I was just kind of like that was
fine that was fine that was okay oh this
one was a little bit better than that
one
and I just kept seeing on social media
all this this talk about like TV shows
and then I started going into it and I
started watching TV shows and one of the
shows that I fell in love with during
the pandemic was normal people
and normal people is with uh Daisy Edgar
Jones she's now in fresh and she has the
crawdads movie coming out and
she is just electrifying I I don't I
don't know how else to put it but her
and I believe the guy's name is Paul
Moscow I think that's a Sam Pascal
something like that uh might be
butchering that but it's Paul something
and this it's a very intimate Love Story
between these two people who are just
not right for one another but they're
trying to make it work and they each
have their problems
and I just remember sitting through this
and it's it's really depressing it's
really heavy
but I just remember when I finished it I
was like wow what an experience like it
made me feel
how I used to feel when I went to the
movies
and then I started watching more TV
shows whether it was like comedies like
doll face or Ted lasso that everyone's
connected with or hacks or only murders
in the building or severance
and I started having this weird pivot
where I was like
as much as I love going to the movies
is this movie that I'm going to see
gonna be as good as hacks or as good as
Severance or as good as Ted lasso and
it's weird to say this as someone who
grew up with such a fond memory of
movies and who loves movies with all his
heart
to sort of pause and kind of say
you know what I got an invite for Crimes
of the future should I go to that or
should I finish watching the dropout
and it's really really weird to have
that happen when you feel so dead set
against something for so long
but
to answer your question I know it was
like a roundabout way of getting there
I I used to go five days a week you know
when before the pandemic it was like
literally any screening that came off
Scott Menzel is there I would be going
and then it just changed because not
only with the gas prices and like
valuing of time a little bit more like I
I kind of had this realization like not
every movie needs to be seen on the big
screen
so
I'll never forget it is it's moving and
I don't mean to to crap on this movie
but like it's something that really
bothered me was they wouldn't send me a
link to see the card counter it's the
Oscar Isaac movie
and I had to do the junket for it
and I drove down to a screening room
and truthfully I didn't really like the
movie there's elements of it that I kind
of enjoyed but as a whole it just didn't
work for me
and I remember sitting in traffic
driving home and I'm like why did I have
to drive to see this
like I would have had the exact same
reaction watching this on my couch that
I would have had driving all the way
here in fact it probably would have been
a little bit better because I would have
been like Ah that's fine where now I'm
gonna lean a little bit more negative
towards it because the experience that I
had driving to the theater two people
being in the theater like like they
couldn't even fill up the screening room
it was like two people in the theater
and it's like why why
and I know people always argue the fact
that like movies need to be experienced
on the big screen
and I think it was James Gunn who said
this
but
movies have a very short life expectancy
on a big screen
they they're there for a couple of
months and then they live whether it's
on DVD on demand streaming whatever it
is nowadays
so as much as I enjoy the spectacle of
like watching like a top gun Maverick on
the big screen and that movie needs to
be experienced on the big screen
a movie like card counter where it's
just like a drama like where there's no
big set pieces there's not a lot of
action there's not a lot going on I can
enjoy that at home so my viewing habits
have pivoted from going like five days a
week
to kind of going to maybe three at most
uh and I'm more selective of what I'm
gonna drive to see because again there's
so much other content out there then I'm
like okay do I really need to see this
movie before everyone else like yes I
need to see Thor love and Thunder
but do I need to see the card counter
before everyone else or can that wait
until that plays five minutes from my
house and I'll just go randomly on a
Saturday night
I was gonna bring up the fact that I'm
in that camp too where I thought that TV
was whatever and and I've pivoted as
well yeah it's crazy yeah I I I I I feel
like I'm
I just feel like I'm being like a
traitor in a weird way to the industry
but I think a lot of people are starting
to come that that turn that corner now I
think a lot of people are just
connecting with things and they're like
wow these shows are better and I think
it's even the Studio's fault like Marvel
is turning their products
into TV shows so when you have a Wanda
Vision which to me is better than most
of these phase four movies I mean it's
way better than eternals it's way better
than doctor strange it's better than
Thor love and thunder so you have this
TV show that I think has more emotion
more depth
that
of course people are going to have the
option do I really want to go see this
or am I going to stay at home and watch
this
what's the longest you can go without
watching a movie
I would say
probably
a day or two
it's weird like
we talk about addiction all the time
entertainment is sort of addiction
whether it's
watching a trailer
or a TV show or being the first to see a
movie
there's something that is wired up there
where you just feel this need to
experience it
and the only time where I don't feel I
need to go to a movie every day
or every other day
is after I get back from a film festival
because in film festivals I go hard and
when I say I go hard I'm going from the
first screening of the day usually at
nine o'clock in the morning
until the last screening at the of the
day at 10 o'clock if you're at Sundance
it's 12 or at South by as well so I'm
literally going non-stop from nine
o'clock in the morning sometimes until
two o'clock in the morning watching
movies
and when I'm
done with a film festival
that's like the time where I can step
back for like a week and be like you
know what
I think I'm okay if I don't go
but then what happens in our industry is
that you get these nice little things
called screening invites and you're like
oh man that that's right that screen is
coming up and then even though I said to
myself I'm not gonna go for a week
oh well Batman's on Thursday I gotta go
see Batman on Thursday and that's what
happens yeah that would be difficult to
be sitting that entire time but I know
it when you when it's being like fed to
you you have no other choice oh no no
and I mean you can't Pro you can't
process everything right that's that's
the the one thing I will say about film
festivals that I think is very
interesting
in a weird way you're doing yourself and
the filmmakers and the storytellers a
little bit of a disservice because if
you see a movie that is like phenomenal
like that like knocks your socks off
at like nine o'clock in the morning and
then you have one at noon
you're going to be riding this high from
this movie that you're going to go into
the next movie
and it's going to be very very hard for
that movie to top when you just watched
and then the opposite can be said you
can watch the most horrendous movie at
nine o'clock in the morning and be like
I hope the day gets better because
you know that movie I just sat through
what a piece of crap and then you go in
the next movie and you almost have like
this well this was so much better so
it's almost like you oh over hype it a
little bit and I've been I've been
I've been very guilty of this I think
like when you see stuff it's sort of
at Film Festival specifically you kind
of feel the audience reaction you kind
of feel the crowd and I've been on both
sides of that where people have been
really enjoying stuff and I've been like
in pain like Centrist like oh my God
what is over I don't want to be here
anymore
or the opposite of where like I've
really enjoyed something and you can
tell like everyone around me is like not
feeling it but I do think that the more
stuff that you watch
back to back to back the harder it is to
have appropriate expectations and
reactions towards
because
what I found myself is that when I hit
in a middle ground like if I see
something really bad and then something
really good then the rest of the stuff I
kind of walk out of and go oh it's fine
it's a very weird
to explain and experience but if you go
to a film festival and you've done it
for like numerous numerous years like I
have you'll sort of understand what I'm
saying is that seeing four or five
things back to back
is not always the best way of doing it
but you feel like you almost have to
because it's like oh I don't know when
this movie is going to come out and then
there's this always this urge of like I
want to be the first person to see it I
want to be one of the first to see this
I want to be the the champion of this
movie like I I think back to CODA you
know I saw that at Sundance and that was
the movie where like I saw it I fell in
love with it and I was like this is
going to be the awards movie
and I and I literally rode that train
and everyone was like Scott you're crazy
you're crazy you're crazy and you know
in those last two months going into the
Oscars going from sag to seeing it kind
of sweep everything moving forward from
that it was it was it was great to see